>>PRESIDENT BIDEN IS IN
MINNOTA TONIGHT AS HE TOURS
THE COUNTRY TO TOUT THE BENEFITS
FROM HIS NEW INFRASTRUCTURE W.
HERE IN WASHINGTON, THOUGH,
THERE ARE NEW ROADBLOCKS TO THE
REST OF THE PRESIDENT'S AGENDA
THAT ARE UNFOLDING RIGHT NOW.
LET'S DISCUSS THIS AND MORE WITH
MITCH LANDRIEU.
RECENTLY TAPPED BY PRESIDENT
BIDEN TO OVERSEE THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
INFRASTRUCTURE LAW.
HE'S JOINING US NOW FOR HIS
FIRST INTERVIEW SINCE TAKING THE
JOB.
HE'S THE FORMER MAYOR OF NEW
ORLEANS.
MAYOR, THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
JOINING US.
LET'S TALK ABOUT WHAT'S GOING
ON.
THE PRESIDENT RIGHT NOW IN
MINNESOTA TOUTING THE BIPARTISAN
INFRASTRUCTURE LAW, BUT A LOT OF
THIS FUNDING WILL GO TO
LONG-TERM PROJECTS, THREE YEARS,
FIVE YEARS, TEN YEARS DOWN THE
ROAD.
HOW LONG WILL IT TAKE UNTIL
AMERICANS FEEL THE IMPACT OF ALL
OF THIS IN THEIR DAILY LIVES?
>> WOLF, THANKS FOR HAVING ME.
AS YOU MENTIONED, THE PRESIDENT
IS IN MINNESOTA TODAY AT THE
DAKOTA COUNTY TECHNICAL COLLEGE
WHERE HE'S TALKING ABOUT NEW
JOBS FOR A NEW FUTURE FOR
WORKING CLASS AMERICANS.
THIS MORNING BEFORE HE LEFT HE
WAS THRILLED TO BE GOING BECAUSE
THIS REALLY IS THE PICTURE OF
WHAT HE WANTS AMERICA TO BECOME
AND THE CHANCES HE WANTS TO GIVE
TO WORKING CLASS FOLKS THAT
ACTUALLY ARE GOING TO REBUILD
AMERICA.
THAT'S THE ONLY WAY IT'S EVER
BEEN DONE.
IT'S VERY INTERESTING FOR 50
YEARS WE'VE BEEN WAITING TO GET
THIS DONE.
THE LAST THREE OR FOUR
PRESIDENTS HAVE TRIED AND
PRESIDENT BIDEN AND HIS TEAM
WITH THE HELP OF A BIPARTISAN
CONGRESS PUT US OVER THE GOAL
LINE.
NOW WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY AS
THE PRESIDENT SAID TO REBUILD
THE ECONOMY FROM THE BOTTOM UP
AND THE MIDDLE OUT.
AND THAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
BECAUSE WE'RE ABOUT TRANSFORMING
THE ECONOMY SO THAT WE CAN
COMPETE AND WIN THE 21st
CENTURY.
THERE IS SOME MONEY GOING OUT OF
THE DOOR AS WE SPEAK.
I SPOKE TO A NUMBER OF GOVERNORS
THIS WEEK.
THE INFRASTRUCTURE TEAM TODAY.
THERE'S $100 MILLION IN
BROADBAND MONEY AT A MINIMUM FOR
EACH STATE IF IT'S APPLIED FOR
AS WE SPEAK.
THERE'S ALSO FORMULA FUNDING
THROUGH THE DEPARTMENT OF
TRANSPORTATION AND, OF COURSE,
ACROSS OTHER AGENCIES THERE'S
MONEY THAT'S AVAILABLE NOW.
BUT AS YOU SAID, WE'RE ABOUT
BUILDING THE FUTURE OF THE
COUNTRY.
IT'S A LOT EASIER TO TEAR DOWN
SOMETHING AND QUICKER THAN TO
BUILD IT AND THE AMERICAN PUBLIC
UNDERSTANDS IT.
WE GET INTO THE BUSINESS OF
MAKING SURE ROADS, BRIDGES AND
LEAD PIPES ARE CHANGED AND WE
CREATE GOOD-PAYING JOBS.
AMERICANS WILL SEE THAT BENEFIT
AND KNOW THIS WAS AN INVESTMENT
IN THE LONG-TERM FUTURE OF OUR
COUNTRY.
>> THE PRESIDENT BACKED AWAY
FROM THE INITIAL PLAN TO PASS
INFRASTRUCTURE AND THE LARGER
SOCIAL SPENDING BILL IN TANDEM.
NOW THERE'S VERY LITTLE
INDICATION THAT SENATOR JOE
MANCHIN, FOR EXAMPLE, WANTS TO
MOVE AHEAD WITH THE BROADER
SOCIAL SPENDING BILL.
HOW DOES PRESIDENT BIDEN GET HIM
ON BOARD WHEN MANCHIN HAS MAJOR
RESERVATIONS ABOUT A LOT MORE
SPENDING, FOR EXAMPLE?
>> YOU SAW OVER THE LAST COUPLE
OF MONTHS THE DIFFICULTY THAT
THE WHITE HOUSE AND CONGRESS HAD
IN GETTING PASSED THE
INFRASTRUCTURE BILL, MUCH LESS
THEY BUILD BACK BETTER PLAN.
THEY'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO
WORK ON THAT.
I THINK THE PRESIDENT HAS FULL
CONFIDENCE THAT AT THE END OF
THE DAY, THE TEAM WILL BE THERE
TO PUT THE SECOND PIECE OF THIS
TOGETHER.
ON THE INFRASTRUCTURE PIECE THE
PRESIDENT ASKED ME TO HELP HIM
WITH, ONE OF THE THINGS THAT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT IS THAT WE NOW
EXECUTE.
AND THAT'S THE MUCH HARDER PART
OF THE JOB.
AND SO WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT
THIS, IN TERMS OF REBUILDING THE
COUNTRY, THERE HAS TO BE
HORIZONTAL AND VERTICAL
INTEICATION.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT, THE
MAYORS, THE PARISH PRESIDENTS,
THE TRIBAL LEADERS ALL HAVE TO
BE ON THE SAME PAGE.
ONE TEAM, ONE FIGHT, MAKING SURE
THE MONEY GETS TO WHERE IT'S
SUPPOSED TO GO.
WHEN THE PRESIDENT WAS THE VICE
PRESIDENT AND OVERSAW THIS FOR
PRESIDENT OBAMA, HE WAS REALLY
INTERESTED IN MAKING SURE THE
MONEY GOT WHERE IT WAS SUPPOSED
TO GO AND MAKE SURE THERE'S
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY.
THAT WE MOVE FAST BUT ALSO MOVE
SMART AND AS WE BUILD, WE BUILD
BACK BETTER.
WHAT DOES THE BETTER MEAN?
THE BETTER MEANS WE FOCUS ON
CLIMATE, ON EQUITY, ON RACIAL
EQUITY AS WELL AND MAKE SURE WE
BUILD BACK WITH AMERICAN-MADE
PRODUCTS.
AND THAT BRINGS ITS OWN
CHALLENGES AS WELL.
SO THERE'S ALWAYS A BALANCE HERE
IN GETTING STUFF IN THE GROUND
AND GETTING IT COMING OUT.
AND THE AMERICAN PEOPLE NEED TO
BE CONFIDENT THAT WHEN WE BUILD
AMERICA BACK, IT'S GOING TO BE
BETTER WHEN WE'RE FINISHED.
>> IF THAT SOCIAL SPENDING BILL
IS ALSO PASSED, WILL YOU BE IN
CHARGE OF IMPLEMENTING THAT?
>> I HAVEN'T BEEN GIVEN ANY
INDICATION.
I'M NOT TRYING TO TAKE THAT JOB.
THIS ONE IS BIG ENOUGH.
$1.2 TRILLION.
IT'S THE BIGGEST ONE PASSED
SINCE DWIGHT EISENHOWER.
I'M HAPPY TO HELP ANY WAY THAT I
CAN.
>> I'M SURE YOU ARE.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT EVERYTHING ON
DEMOCRATS' PLATES RIGHT NOW,
PASSING THE NATIONAL DEFENSE
AUTHORIZATION ACT, AVOIDING A
GOVERNMENT SHUTDOWN, THAT'S
CRITICAL.
RAISING THE DEBT LIMIT, ALSO
WILL THAT PUSH TALKS ON THIS --
WILL THAT PUSH THE TALKS ON THIS
SPENDING -- SOCIAL SPENDING BILL
INTO NEXT YEAR BECAUSE THERE'S
SO MUCH THAT NEEDS TO BE DONE IN
DECEMBER.
>> WELL, I THINK THE MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS CAN DO A LOT OF THINGS
AT ONCE.
AND I FEEL CONFIDENT THAT THE
PRESIDENT IS GOING TO BE ABLE TO
GET IT DONE.
I THINK EVERYBODY HOPES IT
DOESN'T GET PUSHED INTO THE NEXT
YEAR AND THEY'LL PUSH HARD TO
GET IT ALL DONE.
IT'S WITHIN CONGRESS' HANDS TO
DO IT.
BUT I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO GET
IT DONE.
I'M INTERESTED IN TURNING DIRT
AND REALLY CHANGING THE FUTURE
OF AMERICA FOR THE BETTER.
>> THE WHITE HOUSE SAYS
INFLATION, HIGHER PRICES, GAS
PRICES FOR EXAMPLE, SUPPLY CHAIN
ISSUES WILL SUBSIDE WHEN WE GET
THE PANDEMIC UNDER CONTROL.
NOW WITH THIS NEW OMICRON
VARIANT SPREADING, POTENTIALLY,
NOT YET HERE IN THE UNITED
STATES, AS FAR AS WE KNOW BUT
EVENTUALLY IT ALMOST CERTAINLY
WILL BE HERE IS IT TIME TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THESE PROBLEMS COULD
BE WITH US FOR A LONG TIME, THAT
THIS IS NOT TRANSITORY?
>> WELL, I'M NOT READY TO SAY
THAT.
I DON'T THINK WE KNOW.
THERE ARE LOTS OF THINGS IN OUR
LIVES WE CAN'T CONTROL.
I THINK I CAN SPEAK ON BEHALF OF
ALL THE AMERICAN PEOPLE WHEN I
CAN SAY THE LAST YEAR AND A HALF
HAS BEEN A LOT.
WITH THE RISE OF THIS NEW VIRUS
IT ADDS A LEVEL OF UNCERTAINTY.
BUT I FEEL VERY CONFIDENT THAT
THE PRESIDENT AND HIS TEAM HAVE
BEEN DOING EVERYTHING THEY CAN
WITHIN THEIR POWER AND CONTROL
TO MAKE SURE THAT THIS IS
TRANSITORY AND THEY HAVE PUT A
LOT OF PLANS IN PLACE TO MAKE
THAT HAPPEN.
I THINK THAT ALL OF THE EXPERTS
AND ON TV TODAY HAVE SAID THE
BEST WAY FOR AMERICANS TO
PROTECT OURSELVES IS TO GET
VACCINATED AND TO GET BOOSTED.
THAT'S THE SUREST WAY TO GIVE US
THE TOOLS THAT WE NEED TO MOVE
INTO WHERE THIS, IN FACT, IS
TRANSITORY AND WE CAN GET INTO
BUILDING AMERICA AS WE'VE TALKED
ABOUT BEFORE.
>> CERTAINLY IS CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT TO GET VACCINATED AND
GET BOOSTED,